never let a crisis go to waste
every time a crisis appears that
sentiment follows take Democrat Jackie
Speier who tribes Trump for not
cancelling rallies over the virus the
fact that he is not willing to cancel
his various rallies suggests that he is
willing to place even his most ardent
supporters at risk I think that he is
showing unfortunately why he is so
ill-prepared to guide our country during
this time of crisis like she cares for
his supporters so why just demand that
from Trump and not Bernie or Joe is it
just a coincidence such an order
coincides with a political agenda
what's Jackie's next demand you know
Republicans shouldn't vote in November
just to be safe from those toxic
contagious voting booths yeah I never
let a crisis go to waste that's what the
Russians were thinking when they tanked
the oil market and put yet another nail
in the collusion coffin then there's
Chuck Todd's wishful thinking
hmm this virus could be Trump's Iran
hostage crisis that you and I were
talking about and we were talking about
just before the break what the Iran
hostage crisis was the final year of
Carter's presidency not his fault but
it's it's a test in real time and this
is what this is seems to be yeah I mean
it's what this does hold the potential
if it goes badly to become a kind of
Jimmy Carter like scenario where the
public just says can't wake up with this
anxiety every day we got to have some
kind of leadership mmm so Chuck says
this is what it seems to be for Trump
does that sound like a fact to you now
you could blame this idiocy on
polarization but the swine flu killed
thousands under Obama and I don't recall
the media attacking him like this
because he was their guy then there's
Hurricane Katrina a natural disaster
made worse by corrupt local government
but the media blamed George Bush because
he's a Republican and not their guy so
that's the pattern if the media in Dems
hate the current president then crisis
is their tool it isn't new what's new a
president who responds in kind because
that's Trump now is feistiness won't
slow our country's great ability to
handle
threat it's what got him to close the
borders which was pandas racist in the
media but whatever Trump does or doesn't
do won't make any difference to the
press never let a crisis go to waste
they think maybe they'll help them in
November all right Jesse what are your
thoughts on how things are going I would
say the media is like a food critic that
can't cook all they do is criticize and
I was thinking if Barack Obama were
president during the coronavirus the
media would say he's doing a great job
even if he wasn't the president has been
very aggressive with the travel banning
the quarantine eing the accelerating of
the vaccine and he's been out on
television every single day taking
questions from the press and telling
people to go to work and remain calm
what if he'd done the opposite what if
he'd stopped shaking hands what if he
did cancel rallies what if he holds
himself up refused to take questions and
what would the media say then they would
say the president didn't have a grip on
this he was totally AWOL and he was
fear-mongering
so no matter what the president does
he's going to get heat for it the point
is this if you criticize the president
do something with specifics don't just
say the guy's been an abject failure and
is unprepared if you say the testing
kits were slow that's fine if you say
there's mixed messaging point to an
example but don't say this is just a
sample here from three people Trump is a
sociopath purposely tanking the markets
he's a failure ABS artists and he has an
unscientific response that's just not
true gavin newsom governor of california
was asked how the president has been
doing and he said every time we've asked
for something the president has
responded immediately and his
administration has given us everything
we need so it's not true that the
president is miss handling this the
media is miss handling it they're trying
to press the panic button to score
political points and that's fine the
president just needs to say listen don't
touch your face don't go on a cruise
everybody remain calm we're gonna handle
this America always wins we always beat
these things let's do things made in
America let's tighten the borders and
we're gonna beat it and I think if you
sticks to that message that's a strong
lesson
Juan let me play Rahm Emanuel also
talking about these rallies and I want
to get your take on the rallies in
general you're gonna have a point within
about two months where you cannot have
big events together he is not going to
be able to have his rallies and it is
gonna psychologically the office is
isolating enough and his inability to
get the admiration the adulation from
that crowd is gonna psychologically
torment him and his isolation is gonna
get more intense and his tweets are
gonna get more vicious no one I actually
think it's a legitimate question about
rallies whether they are Trump or
they're Bernie I think with the age of
people that come to these things I would
be concerned but he pollutes that
message by taking some kind of perverse
pleasure out of it and I think that like
makes it so that well screw you cuz I
can't trust that guy because he's he's
find him he's finding a political
pleasure right yeah you mean like going
out and having a press conference about
the coronavirus wearing a make America
great oh that was Donald Trump
politicizing or calling the governor
Washington snake oh that was Donald
Trump
I'll have legitimate Brian I mean I
think that you know if Jackie Spears is
the best example you have of Democrat I
don't see Democrats being so political
about this in fact I mean what I see is
that people are concerned they want
reliable straight information and the
President had said in the past all we
know if you want to test you can get it
then it turns out no the tests weren't
available or the president says you know
this is just like the flu it's no big
deal we get we got it under control and
then the numbers keep going up and
people become more excited now you have
even Republican members of Congress
saying they're self-quarantine like Ted
Cruz the senator from Texas which
Democrat which media kind of loved well
I don't know I'm just telling you this
truth I mean that's a fact I didn't I
didn't tell Ted Cruz and the media
didn't tell Ted Cruz today that's what
I'm saying no I don't care if they get a
kick out of it but I do you would care
about the politics I'm just saying
listen know I've I've always said to you
what we should be caring about here is
people who have are anxious and worried
about the impact of the quencher virus
which is why and so when you have a
president that is not seen as reliable
and right now we have polls most
Americans don't think he's doing a very
good job with this I wonder why yeah
Policy poll just said he is not a
disapprove of his conduct of the handler
the Kona virus more than 50 double
digits in every single battle guess I
just saw this poll cause came out
yesterday so the point over the man I
think the biggest true test for in terms
of anxiety is the stock market which
absolutely imploded today yes and what
you see is people are anxious again
about lack of knowing where we're going
what is the situation first Italy
locking down Israel saying anybody
flying all that is okay we can a so this
is a test for the president that's
absolutely true and it's a big one
with the economy with trying to keep
people calm also doing two things at
once not overreacting
no under-reacting things are going to
change everyday the number of cases are
going to change with the CDC and the
president have talked about so
information is going to be different
from day to day it will not be the same
so you can't accuse the president of not
being reliable just because information
is changing and the administration is
holding a press conference every single
day with the vice president and all
these officials to give a daily update
directly to the American people directly
to reporters to try and let them know
what is going on and how they can best
handle the situation but when it comes
to the politics of this the DAO
especially in the stock market is the
exact economic collapse that Democrats
have been asking for you had Bill
Maher's saying he hoped that the economy
would collapse he doesn't care if it
hurts anybody because that's how he
knows the president will get out of
office the economy was the big barrier
that the Democrats had to entry when it
came to winning the White House this
time around and now they're loving the
idea that President Trump made be taken
off the campaign trail because he can't
hold rallies but he may have to self
quarantine and not be able to talk
directly to the American people and push
back against momentum the Democrats have
now in the primary process you coupled
that with the economy they like that
momentum getting pulled away from the
president so again things will change
this is China's fault China did this to
the world by the Communist Party in
China covered this up they censored it
which made it spread and they lied about
it and that's why we are here we're not
here because of the President Trump
because Americans
here because the Chinese Communist Party
and Democrats be criticizing more on
that than the president so Dana we
really the impact on the stock market
wasn't the coronavirus it might have had
been part of it but it was we have an
oil price war going on that's having the
impact like I'm not a big market expert
but I don't think you could say that it
doesn't have anything to do with
criminal fibers obviously that last week
it was it had gyrations and as Daikin
pointed out on Friday though Dow ended
of the week up a little bit then what
happened over the weekend is that Saudi
Arabia and Russia decided that this
would be a really good time to have a
production war
yeah and they started having this
argument over the weekend and that
spooked the futures market and that
means that if you saw like if you work
in energy in the energy field and now
oil is down at $31 a barrel like that's
a problem yeah for the economy and for
people that work in it and I also think
if I could just have one second sure
that said the president's gonna get
criticized no matter what right so it's
fine so then what should they try to do
moving forward and I think one of the
things that they made that he made a
mistake on early on was when the doctor
from the CDC said an outbreak in America
is inevitable mm-hmm and she got pushed
to the side she was right like there was
an outbreak but it was a manageable
outbreak right all of this is manageable
I think what the president and the team
and maybe you'll hear from president
vice president Penn's here in a minute
is it going forward we are going to have
a situation where our hospitals and our
medical teams are overwhelmed that it's
just going to happen and so how are we
preparing for that what are we doing for
that and actually the federal government
being able to release an eight point
three billion dollars to the state local
governments that are on the frontlines
as gavin newsom said like everything
we've asked for we need I think if the
president starts preparing people like
this is likely to happen we're gonna
have some closures everything's gonna be
fine that would be a good thing to do
yeah and I think there's I mean I my
question is we talked about overwhelmed
medical facilities but what do they do
with all of those hundreds of thousands
of flu patients since we know fifty to
eighty thousand that times died so we
don't we never we never hear about that
that's kind of think that they that we
have treatments for them
right there's palliative care or there's
vaccines or there's something like for
this but right now
a lot of death in that anyway